they are the almost forgotten victims of
the early days of the war in ukraine
yeven vusic has kept watch as they stand
in an anonymous freezer van in an
anonymous car park in this unit alone 12
bodies still not identified still not
claimed by their loved ones
we would like to bury these people it is
a long time they have been lying here
more than three months relatives are
coming here and they are shocked they
cannot identify the body simply by
looking of them
many people left for other countries so
these victims are lying here unclaimed
in other units nearby 30 soldiers and
another one 40 other civilians some
recovered from deep in a nearby forest
the russians built their positions in
this wood facing towards kiev when they
were forced to withdraw that's when
investigators moved in and they found
one mass grave and they think around
here there will be many more
just last month ukrainian forensic teams
found the site and started gathering
evidence they pulled seven bodies from a
tiny grave each victim shot in the head
and dumped their crime being male and
old enough to fight against the russians
evan vusick was there that day helping
out watching the ground give up its
secrets
at the moment i sleep okay but when i
excuse the bodies of children even
though they are not my children and i do
have two children it's horrible because
even with alcohol i can get it out of my
mind
from each victim they've taken dna one
day their family might claim them give
them a proper burial
the man heading the police investigation
into what happened
told me no matter how difficult these
crimes must be investigated
this should be important not just
ukrainians but to the whole
international community this is very
important the same as the investigations
into what happened during world war ii
we must investigate the army of the
russian federation the army commanders
this message should be delivered
the bodies will sit for a few more weeks
then they will be quietly buried but for
now they set silent witnesses in an
investigation into war crimes and murder
alan fisher al-jazeera marotzka ukraine